au bout de l'effort Nathan d’au fins
termine deuxième sur cette course au
point organisé dans le cadre du Grand
Prix de Vélizy une compétition à
domicile pour cette ini montant dans ce
vélo de national de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est la première de l'année sur la
saison please donc c'est pour voir un
peu les adversaires par rapport à moi et
je m'étais fixé un podium bon bah j'ai
réussi donc je suis bien content au
total ils étaient 124 engagés sur cette
huitième édition du Grand Prix de
vélizyn compétition nationale avec des
cadets juniors et des élites un concept
imaginé en 2015 par le C Vélizy 78 c'est
une une tradition que de vouloir
organiser des épreuves surpiste il n'y
en a très peu d'organiser en
Île-de-France et nous on marque un point
d'honneur donc à organiser chaque année
le Grand Prix de Vélizy mais également
au minimum un championnat
d'Île-de-France cette année 30 féminine
était inscrite pour ce rendez-vous une
première parmi les têtes d'affiches ont
retrouvé notamment Julie Michaud
quatrième des championnats d'Europe
élite en par équipe et cinquième par
équipe au Championnat du Monde 2022 sur
ce vélo Drôme mon entraîneur m'a dit
Julie prend du plaisir et
pour on fait même l'endurance
au jour pas fait d'endurance et donc
c'est vraiment pour m'amuser et me
remettre dans le dans l'ambiance Julie
Michaud rejoint la longue liste des
membres de l'équipe de France ayant
participé à la compétition actuellement
tous les pistards internationaux
tricolore ont couru le Grand Prix de
Vélizy un rendez-vous qui reviendra
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition